[Music]
with the 2020 presidential election fast
approaching I thought now would be a
good time to take a look at the American
political spectrum and discuss just how
little disagreement there actually is
within American politics
let's start with a tool we're probably
all familiar with the political compass
test this simple test has you answer a
series of questions then based on your
responses gives you a set of two values
one for the x-axis and one for the
y-axis which it uses to plot your
overall political ideology on the chart
for those unfamiliar with the compass
it's a roughly accurate way to help you
understand where your opinions fit in
the wide range of political thought the
x-axis represents economics with an
economy run by a cooperative collective
agency on the far left and a market left
to the devices of competing corporations
and individuals on the far right the
y-axis represents social stances with
the very top representing a complete
obedience to Authority and the very
bottom representing a maximization of
personal freedom a lot of people get
hung up on the left-right portion and
conflate one side or the other with
authoritarianism this is a mistake any
point on the left-right spectrum is
capable of authoritarianism for example
you'll find leaders like Kim jong-un on
the left and a Dolf Hitler on the right
there's a vocal subset of figures on the
right who love to claim that Hitler was
a leftist but we'll get to that later in
the video to give you a few examples of
notable figures from each quadrant
you'll find Mao Stalin Kim and Mugabe in
the authoritarian left quadrant
Hitler Viktor Orban Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump in the authoritarian right
einar and Milton Friedman Friedrich
Hayek and Gary Johnson in the
libertarian right and Ghandi Thomas
Paine Bernie Sanders and Nelson Mandela
in the libertarian left so to reiterate
the x-axis is economic stances and the
y-axis is social stances as a small
disclaimer no simple political test is
the most accurate determinant for actual
human ideology a two axis chart is
simply not nuanced enough to be a
hundred percent correct but the
political compass is a useful tool for
understanding broad trends and it's
helpful for this type of analysis now
let's look at the compass for the 2020
presidential race interesting right
maybe not what you expected there's a
whole lot of yelling and name-calling
between presidential candidates and
their supporters and detractors but when
you take their voting records and plot
them on a chart like this it becomes
apparent that there's really not that
much separating most of the candidates
and bernie sanders who many people paint
as a communist barely squeaked his way
onto the left side of the spectrum
what's going on here the reason a figure
like bernie only just passes the center
line is that the political compass isn't
just mapping american sensibilities but
the entirety of political thought the
american political spectrum stops right
about here anything beyond Bernie's
moderate social democratic platform is
absolutely unthinkable in modern-day
America so why does our national
political conversation stop so close to
the center line one of the biggest
reasons is the legacy of the Cold War
the Red Scare was scary in the days when
schools had nuclear attack drills anyone
even remotely critical of the prevailing
American political model was seen as a
communist and sympathetic to the
nation's greatest enemy this led to
years of crackdowns on left-leaning
political groups
McCarthy's communists witch hunts and
the general circling of the wagons
around the quote American Way of life
when the Soviet Union fell and the
Eastern Bloc countries got both
democracy and a free market at the same
time the two axes of the political
compass got tangled up this bundling led
many to falsely equate free-market
capitalism with democracy and more
left-wing politics with authoritarianism
if you need proof of just how ingrained
this type of thinking has become in
America take a look at these pictures
the terminology is always the same blank
equals communism apparently keeping
baskin-robbins closed so people don't
die from a deadly virus as communism who
would have guessed when the incredibly
popular Ronald Reagan came along and
launched his campaign of deregulation
tax rate reductions increased military
spending and union-busting he put the
final nail in the coffin of American
left politics since then we've lived in
an era of consensus politicians may
appear to disagree on many subjects and
they probably truly see each other as
complete opposites but the truth of the
matter is that with very few exceptions
the entirety of American politics is
contained within a single quadrant of
the political compass the entire
national political dialogue is framed to
begin and end on the right so for the
sake of expanding the national dialogue
let's talk a little bit about the
neglected left side of the spectrum but
first we need to put one erroneous claim
to rest there are some notable figures
on the right who claim that Adolf Hitler
was a leftist everyone's favorite
felonious filmmaker Dinesh D'Souza and
fail son extraordinaire ben shapiro are
particularly vocal about it their
argument usually boy
down to well the Nazis were called the
National Socialist Party checkmate
okay sure but the Nazis were no more of
a Socialist Party than North Korea is
democratic by the people or a republic
it's the same tactic taken by autocrats
throughout history they pick a term
their citizens associate with something
good
usually freedom or democratic or peoples
and they adopt it to make themselves
look good
Hitler himself said our adopted term
socialist has nothing to do with Marxian
socialism so there you go to be fair bad
faith arguments like those from D'Souza
are generally dismissed by most thinking
people but there are plenty of older
folks who get caught in the trap which
is sad because they're completely
unaware of the fact that they're being
taken advantage of but while we're on
the topic of socialism I think it would
be useful to explain what the ideology
really represents after all the term has
made quite a comeback in recent years
with a larger percentage of young people
across America having a more favorable
opinion of socialism than capitalism
socialism in America is a blanket term
for generally leftist ideology a
socialist would advocate for a more
egalitarian society where there's not a
tiny percentage of people hoarding all
the wealth they want to end pointless
Wars like the decades-old conflict in
the Middle East where young men and
women are sent to die and murder other
humans for the sake of the rich and
powerful they advocate for a more humane
society where the sick can get treatment
and not go bankrupt in the process where
small businesses aren't crushed by
multinational corporations and where
people are paid fair wages for their
work they also advocate for worker
control of or at least worker
involvement in enterprise that's a key
point that most Americans seem to miss
when someone shouts that the government
issuing a quarantine is communism
they're more than a little off base
government doing stuff is not communism
or even socialism if the US government
were to establish a more robust safety
net for workers laid off during the
pandemic that still wouldn't be
socialism nor should such a government
be considered leftist if workers don't
have a say in how enterprises run you
have a left-leaning centrist government
at most it's important to have at least
a general understanding of what terms
mean when we're talking about politics
you hear a lot of right versus left
freedom versus communism bickering in
the u.s. but when you hear something
like that remember just how similar
mainstream politicians are these days
don't buy into the fear-mongering and
take the time to educate yourself about
the whole spectrum of political
not just the stunted American variety
while the political compass test isn't
perfect it's a good place to start if
you'd like to understand more about your
opinions and who shares them there's a
link to take the test in the description
below as well as links to the eight
values and nine axis quizzes which
attempt to further explore your personal
ideology take the results from your
quizzes and use them to find books to
read on the subject American political
understanding is not great but by
learning more you can do just a little
bit to fix that problem if you enjoyed
this video and you'd like to see more
like it consider subscribing to stay up
to date with my latest episodes if you
hated it go ahead and drop a thumbs down
and if you really want to help support
my channel I recently started a patreon
which you can find at patreon.com slash
second thought you can check out my
previous episodes by clicking the links
on your screen thanks for watching and
I'll see you next week